my third story is about death when I was
17 I read a quote that went something
like if you live each day as if it was
your last someday you'll most certainly
be right it made an impression on me and
since then for the past 33 years I've
looked in the mirror every morning and
asked myself if today were the last day
of my life
what I want to do what I am about to do
today and whenever the answer has been
no for too many days in a row I know I
need to change something remembering
that I'll be dead soon is the most
important tool I've ever encountered to
help me make the big choices in life
because almost everything all external
expectations all pride all fear of
embarrassment or failure these things
just fall away in the face of death
leaving only what is truly important
remembering that you are going to die is
the best way I know to avoid the trap of
thinking you have something to lose you
are already naked there is no reason not
to follow your heart about a year ago I
was diagnosed with cancer I had a scan
at 7:30 in the morning and it clearly
showed a tumor on my pancreas I didn't
even know what a pancreas was the
doctors told me this was almost
certainly a type of cancer that is
incurable and that I should expect to
live no longer than three to six months
my doctor advised me to go home and get
my affairs in order which is doctors
code for prepare to die it means to try
and tell your kids everything you
thought you'd have the next 10 years to
tell them in just a few months it means
to make sure everything is buttoned up
so that will be as easy as possible for
your family it means to say your
goodbyes
I live with that diagnosis all day later
that evening I had a biopsy where they
stuck an endoscope down my throat
through my stomach into my intestines
put a needle into my pancreas and got a
few cells from the tumor I was sedated
but my wife who was there
told me that when they viewed the cells
under a microscope the doctor started
crying because it turned out to be a
very rare form of pancreatic cancer that
is curable with surgery I had the
surgery and thankfully I'm fine now this
was the closest I've been to facing
death and I hope it's the closest I get
for a few more decades having lived
through it I can now say this to you
with a bit more certainty than when
death was a useful but purely
intellectual concept no one wants to die
even people who want to go to heaven
don't want to die to get there and yet
death is the destination we all share no
one has ever escaped it and that is as
it should be because death is very
likely the single best invention of life
it's life's change agent it clears out
the old to make way for the new right
now the new is you but some day not too
long from now you will gradually become
the old and be cleared away sorry to be
so dramatic
but it's quite true your time is limited
so don't waste it living someone else's
life
don't be trapped by Dogma which is
living with the results of other
people's thinking don't let the noise of
others opinions drown out your own inner
voice and most important have the
courage to follow your heart and
intuition they somehow already know what
you truly want to become everything else
is secondary